we have so much uh to cover today that i
will not
waste any time as i normally do a lot of
time wasting normally on this program
but not today
uh so we have trump events and biden
harris events to talk about we'll start
with trump donald trump yesterday
very suddenly scheduling a press
briefing uh
right at the time that joe biden and
kamal harris were having their first
joint event which i will cover
momentarily
donald trump sounding very much the same
yesterday as in previous press briefings
not only repeating some of the same
things he said previously but even
repeating the same stuff two three even
four times during yesterday's press
briefing which was weird
um we were it the
it actually went so poorly that fox news
even cut away from it
to instead discuss the biden harris
event if you can believe that but we
will get to that and it does seem like
donald trump was motivated yesterday in
this late scheduled event at least
partially by trying to take attention
away from the biden harris event which
got
much more attention and much larger
viewership
um it was bad from the start donald
trump sounded particularly
slowed down sort of that's an ambulant
trump sleepwalking sleep talking lowest
energy that i've seen from him take a
look
and good evening as we continue to
confront the
china virus we're rebuilding america's
economy like
nobody thought possible actually we're
doing incredibly well stock markets up
almost 300 points again today
while our economy is performing
significantly better than
europe which people have to understand
very
strongly it's performing better than any
market anywhere in the world actually
at the same time europe has experienced
a forty percent
higher excess mortality than the
united states so that's what i call
uh casual xenophobic sin ambulant
trump you'll notice that everything now
is percentages relative to the second
quarter
if you watch this program i warned you
about this after historic declines
and horrible numbers in second quarter
we expected
that now we would start hearing about
relative to the second quarter
this has grown so much that has grown so
much
i won't you're all now briefed on that
because i've been talking about it and
warning you about it for months so i
don't
think i need to spend too much time on
that donald trump still pushing this
idea yesterday that the election will be
a fraud and even mixing it here with
obama gate obamacare of course is this
greatest crime in history
that trump has claimed barack obama
committed we never actually find out
which laws were broken what is the
treason you claim is there
but it doesn't matter it's all being
wrapped up now the greatest fraud
ever perpetrated other than perhaps what
they did to my campaign where they spied
on my campaign president obama
biden and everybody else and they got
caught let's see what happens
this will be one of the greatest frauds
in history
so they're admitting that they want 3.5
billion
and they're not going to do
a deal that's good for the american
people sadly this is working and that's
why i think we need to keep talking
about this yes so fraud all right
whatever it's trump again
but it actually has convinced two-thirds
of republicans 65 percent to be more
precise
that the election may not be fair in
november
this is a strategy and we talked about
it yesterday trump's fixated on it for a
reason and it's because it's good for
him
to continue harping on the election is
not going to be fair the election is
going to be rigged
the election is going to be a fraud now
trump eventually took questions and he
did take more questions than the
previous day when i think he took five
mostly friendly questions and then sort
of skulked off the stage
trump did take questions yesterday he
got a good question about the
coronavirus death toll
donald trump keeps talking about how
cases don't tell us much
because cases are merely an artifact of
testing and because we test so much
as trump says cases don't really tell us
how we compare to other countries
reporter
astutely says well but our death toll is
a nightmare
uh in in absolute terms and in per
capita terms
and trump just deflects and insists on
talking about
cases instead mr president
what is is about you had
graphs about the economics of the topic
but deaths in america are still going up
whereas in europe
right now zero deaths in uk zero deaths
in france
what's going up by cases if you look at
cases and the cases are going up because
we do so much testing and we find it
and i call it fake media gold because we
do so much more testing than any other
country and when you do all that testing
you find cases go ahead steve real fast
so later i'm going to be covering
the biden harris event from yesterday
and you will no doubt
notice that the biden harris event
was on topic and coherent
and substantive whereas with donald
trump it's
deflection and non-answers and
redirections and this actually at one
point got really interesting because fox
news reporter john roberts
asked the key question about trump's
idea for cutting the payroll tax which
he's been floating recently
you probably know if you watched my i
guess that was the
monday tuesday show that the payroll tax
funds
social security so if you permanently
cut the payroll tax
like trump claims he wants to do you
immediately
have a funding issue for social security
a funding issue that you create
nonetheless donald trump not shockingly
when asked about this is completely
incoherent
if if you permanently rescind the
payroll tax
how do you pay for social security we're
taking it out of the general fund
and what we'll do what we'll be doing is
if we do that we'll get it approved in
that case by congress
and we'll take the money from other
places other than we will not take it
from social security
in any way shape or form how do you fund
from the general fund when the general
fund
just incurred a debt of 2.8 trillion
dollars right we're gonna have
tremendous growth
we have tremendous growth you take a
look at what's happening here next year
unless somebody comes in who doesn't
know what they're doing and they start
raising taxes and forcing everybody to
leave the country or
leave their jobs and companies to close
we will have tremendous growth you will
see growth like you haven't seen in a
long time
okay this one he's actually been
claiming
since being a candidate anytime trump
has a policy
that makes no sense from the standpoint
of arithmetic
trump says it might seem like it removes
money and causes a financial shortfall
but it doesn't
because it's going to be so stimulative
that all of this new growth will show up
and the government is going to take in
more money
it's simply not happened i mean the
concept of it is the concept of demand
side
stimulus if you make the right moves
from
a financial standpoint in the economy
you generate growth which creates new
government revenue
it didn't happen with trump's tax cuts
it certainly wouldn't happen
when you cut the pay cutting the payroll
tax which funds social security
will not generate growth such that then
you get even more money from social
security elsewhere this is a shadow
campaign
if it were to succeed to hurt social
security
uh despite claims that it's biden who
will hurt social security
if trump were able to permanently cut
the payroll tax
that would really damage social security
i talked about it in detail
again it was monday or tuesday so i
won't do the the full
analysis again then we get into some
so-called fun
stuff if the term can really apply to
horror show
press briefings take a look at this
feeling that on november
4th somebody's going to announce schools
are open
the country's open everything's open i
really believe a lot of it's done for
political reasons
who want to know the truth i think so
but you're right
online is not the same as being in the
classroom he
really seems to think that the entire
coronavirus response in the united
states
is about him and him alone no one is
going to say on november 4th if the news
on november 4th is biden
defeated trump no one is going to say
open up all the schools because it was
safe all along
the only way november 4th will see
schools opened
is if on november 3rd cases go down 95
percent
the idea that this is all about trump is
just part of his narcissism
part of his delusions of grandeur and
it's a complete and total fantasy
compared with ebola where two people
died in 2014
the day of the midterms in november of
2014
ebola criticisms of obama stopped
you can even look at trump's own tweets
leading even in october of 2014
trump was hammering obama on ebola where
two people died
and after the midterms you never heard
about it again essentially
um this was yesterday maybe the most
slowed down
trump that we've ever seen check out
these pauses and of course
without even without the pauses what
trump is saying here would make no sense
when you sit at home in a basement
looking at a computer your brain starts
to wither away
we have a lot of good experience at that
just by taking a look at what's
happening in politics
studies estimate that school closures
last
spring caused the average student to
fall 50 percent behind in math and
roughly
35 percent i mean just just disjointed
incoherent and then the wild and wacky
trump
falling apart refers to doctors as
doctors
which is something else altogether of
course and really continuing to struggle
to speak
the doctors also warned about the risk
of increased abuse
then trump completely unable to say
fatalities multiple times he says
fatalities and again he has this look on
his face
where it's almost like one part of his
brain realizes that the other part
is saying something that doesn't make
sense it's like when he said we need to
know the oranges the citrus fruit the
oranges of the investigation
he had to look like he knew there was a
malfunction
couldn't get control of it very very
similar here with fatilities
it's 99.995 of all fatalities
are adults think of that 99.9
that is extremely close to 100
of all fatalities are
adults children look at you know
yosemites
plasma fatilities just over the last
week
uh come on guys this isn't normal
something is wrong here and then the
last thing before i talk about how fox
news handled this briefing trump quickly
called on the right-wing
propaganda network oan the question was
a complete non-sequitur about
some antifa website redirecting to joe
biden's website
it was just a set up for trump to link
biden
and antifa when there is no such link
i'm not even going to play the question
for you i don't want to give oan
any air time but right after oan said
what about this antifa website that
redirects to joe biden's website
fox news put up on a lower third graphic
trump says biden should denounce antifa
and this is how propaganda is generated
there is no
antifa biden story at all oan
creates such a discussion by asking
a ridiculous question and next thing you
know fox news
has a quote up on the screen about what
trump says biden should do
about antifa last thing this is really
interesting
even fox news had to cut away when
donald trump started ranting about bill
de blasio and
dog whistles about violence in chicago
and the like
fox cut away and said watch the rest on
our website if you want
it's not even believable what's
happening in chicago where
one weekend you have 78 people shot and
18
die in a weekend
and then successive weekends you have so
much of that happening and
it's it's not even it's really not even
believable
and if you let democrats run this
country and we've stopped it from going
other places if you let democrats run
this country
you'll have all of your cities be just
like that
thank you mr president the heads of the
boston and
good evening welcome to washington i'm
brad bear president trump holding his
daily briefing there we have it
streaming on foxnews.com you can see the
rest of it
he started by talking about the success
of the stock market in recent days
what he calls a v-shaped recovery from
the coronavirus shutdown the president
also promising that checks
so fox news saying no more for us
and then very last thing i've said
during my live streams of these events
that donald trump repeats a lot of the
same
things he's been repeating verbatim the
same talking points on the virus since
april or may
it's almost like we haven't had months
in between and 160 000 deaths
the recount put this together and it is
actually
literally verbatim true that trump is
just repeating the same stuff
the united states has now conducted more
than
66 million
population 1.5 million residents of
nursing homes about five times about
five times that of other european
countries
we're on track
so this is all very weird and we had a
contrast yesterday of the alternative
which was
a biden harris event their first event
together
which is what i want to talk about next
if you are
anything like me you probably aren't
thrilled with the idea of going into a
doctor's office right
now and thankfully there's a practical
and affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video